The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: All right.
So we are here.
I'm highlighting
two, because I really
want to keep talking
about solar thermal fuels,
mostly because it really
captures a key problem
that only quantum
mechanics can solve.
OK?
So I really want to
hit that home hard.
Also, because it's the
topic of your next homework,
and also because I'm biased.
I'm more excited
about this than this.
But I want to tell you a little
bit about hydrogen storage
too, and why I think
that's a perfect problem
for atomic-scale
computational modeling.
OK?
So we're going to do a lot
more of solar thermal fuels,
picking up where we did
before, and then a little bit
of hydrogen storage.
Now, before we do that,
I want to keep blending
in some reinforcement
of key basic concepts
that we have touched on,
and we need to make sure
we feel good about them.
So we're going to
feel good today
about energy levels, first
bullet of the outline,
feeling good.
It's a good way
to start, I think.
I didn't need to put
that there, because you
would have felt good anyway.
Right?
But there it is in writing.
We're going to feel good
about energy levels,
and then we're going to keep
talking about solar fuels.
And we'll do a few
calculations, more calculations
on the nanoHUB together.
Right?
Again, no better
way to pass time.
OK?
And then we'll talk
about hydrogen storage.
That's our plan.
Now, like I said, I want
to keep reinforcing--
I did this, and it
put me off balance.
It's excitement.
That's a little bit
more than my usual even.
It's also, I think,
just old age.
I think sometimes, you
get a little off balance.
Anyway, now, point is
that I think probably I
like watch the NBA so
much, because I still
don't want to give up the
idea that I could someday
be in the NBA myself.
So I'm not letting
go of that dream,
but anyway, I want to go back to
one of my original excitements
here about materials
design which
is one of the
things I really want
to make sure we
capture in this class,
designing materials
and computers.
Right?
So I want to take
carbon, and I just
have two or three slides here.
So I want to touch
on what I think
is a really exciting
example of materials design,
and you all know this.
Right?
You know carbon can do this
and this, and many of you
know that carbon can do--
well, where are my fullerenes?
Well, there's some nanotubes.
There's fullerenes inside
of nanotubes, p-pods.
Right?
Now, there's all kinds
of forms of carbon
that there didn't used to
be, or there used to be,
but we didn't see them, and
we couldn't control them.
OK?
And I want to give
you a really, I think,
interesting analysis of one
thing you can do with carbon.
OK?
And then another thing you can
do with it, when you design it,
when you can do
materials design.
So this is what we do with
carbon now that we find in oil.
Right?
We burn it, and there's 1.73
megawatt hours of energy
when you burn a barrel of oil.
Right?
I didn't show you this example.
Did I?
OK.
Because I think it's
a really neat one.
So that's how much energy
is in a barrel of oil,
and it's a lot of energy.
That's a really nice--
oil is amazing.
It's like this incredible
energy-dense, safe,
transportable, storage system.
Right?
It's solar powered.
You all know that
it's made by the sun,
but it's not renewable,
which is a problem,
but it's a really
beautiful fuel.
Now, oil has a lot
of carbon in it
which is what's burning there
and giving you that energy
release.
But there are other things
you can do with that material,
and one thing you can do is
you can make these other forms
of carbon from the oil.
In fact, that's how we
make a lot of our plastics.
OK?
We make a lot of
plastics using oil.
If I take 1%, just 1% of the
carbon in these 159 liters
of oil, just 1% of it, and
I make that into plastic,
then because I know how to
design carbon to be something
else, like fullerenes, I can
make polymers and fullerenes
out of that same element
carbon and put them together--
gesundheit, whoever that was--
and make solar cells,
new kinds of solar cells,
in fact, solar cells made
out of mostly carbon.
If I take 1% of that
carbon that was in here,
and I turn it into this,
which we now know how to do,
then I can make really
bad solar cells.
5% efficient, not so
good, die in one year,
not so good. right?
The efficiency goes down.
Most solar cells, you
get a 20-year warranty.
This one, one-year warranty,
then efficiency is gone.
Even in that case,
this solar cell
over that one year of
really crappy efficiency
will give me 10,000
times as much energy than
by burning the carbon, 10,000.
Now, these are hand-waving
arguments that are
back-of-the-envelope
calculations,
but when you've got five orders
of magnitude to play with,
things are good.
Right?
And this is an example
in the energy space.
This is why I get so excited
about designing materials,
and this in particular, this
is only 100 nanometers thick.
Right?
The solar cell's
thicker, because it's
packaged but the active layer,
the part of the material that's
making the sun turn into
electrons and holes,
something we're going to talk
about in our next example,
in a few weeks.
That part is 100
nanometers thick.
That's atomic scale.
That's the atomic scale.
You can't pack that many
polymers and fullerenes
into 100 nanometers.
Things at the atomic scale and
the quantum mechanical aspects
of that material are
critical, and designing
that material is
something you can
do using atomistic modeling.
So this is what I mean.
You want to give elements
completely new possibilities,
and you can see the
power of doing that.
It changes the way we know
how to use those elements,
and I think that's just
a very powerful concept.
OK.
Any questions
about that example.
So that's my little my material
design example of the day,
if you will.
We should make like a
calendar, each day a new--
OK.
Now, I want to pause and feel
our oneness with energy levels
and basis sets.
So this is, again, going back
to some important key elements
of the computations,
and then we're
going to come back to the
calculations and the example
of the solar thermal fuels.
OK?
Now these are things that
we have talked about,
but they're so
important that I want
to talk about them again and
make sure there's no questions.
Make sure that we are
all on the same page
and know what these things mean.
OK?
So I want to give you,
this is my attempt
at summarizing our beautiful
path to the energy level.
OK?
So let's make sure
we're with it.
All right?
So it all started back
in the day in lecture one
with the Schrodinger equation.
Does everybody recognized that?
Now, that is the
equation we're solving.
When you click
Simulate to calculate
the energy versus separation
in say, I don't know,
n-2, then the equation that's
being solved in a computer
is this one, the
Schrodinger equation.
Now, what are you getting
out of that equation?
Well, what you're
getting are what?
These, what are these?
AUDIENCE: Wave functions.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Thank you, and why
do I want those?
What do they tell me?
AUDIENCE: Probability.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Yeah.
The tell me the probability,
and they tell me more than
that which is what we need
to make sure we understand.
So you see, solving
that equation gives me
wave function, and the wave
functions, well, they're waves.
Right?
They have some shape to them.
They may change in time.
Do we care about that?
Not in this class, not in
this class, in this class,
its all time independent.
So we're doing like a snapshot,
but they may change in time.
But they certainly vary
in space, and that is psi.
Right?
Now, what we talked about
is how these wave functions
themselves, we don't know how
to draw physical meaning from.
That doesn't mean that
they're meaningless,
and this is a really
important point
that we have to feel good about.
OK?
So I'm going to
come back to that,
but we know that when you square
them, we know what they mean,
and that's this.
Right?
So what are These do you
guys remember what these are?
AUDIENCE: Orbitals.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Orbitals, such a bad name,
but anyway, because
why is it a bad name?
AUDIENCE: Because they
don't really orbit.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, totally, but anyway,
these are orbitals.
So these are those wave
functions squared for what?
Who knows what-- but
what system is this?
These are the atomic
orbitals of a hydrogen
atom, one electron, one proton.
OK?
You can solve that analytically.
Now, so we said, OK,
well, this gives us
like an electron sitting in
one of these little wiggles.
OK?
We said that they
go up in energy.
They have different energies.
That's really important.
Each wave function you solve
for has a different energy.
Right?
So you get these functions, and
they have different energies,
and there it is for
hydrogen. There's
the energy for hydrogen. It just
depends on 1 over the principle
quantum number squared.
Right?
Remember, we talked
about how it's quantized?
But these little wiggles,
when you square them,
they give you the picture of
where that electron is going
to be, where it's likely to be.
And we looked at how the
shapes got more complicated,
and what are these
type of orbitals?
AUDIENCE: P
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: p?
And then it goes to other
things, d and then f.
And then we said,
OK, that's nice.
That's great, but also there's
this thing called spin.
OK?
And somebody remind
me what spin is.
AUDIENCE: Property
of the material.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Property
of what thing in particular?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's some
intrinsic angular momentum
that a particle has.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Regardless
of its motion.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
And if that particle
happens to be an electron,
what are your options?
AUDIENCE: In the first one?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Plus or minus.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Plus or minus.
It can only be--
or as we like to say
up or down or as we
like to draw this or that.
Lots of ways of doing this,
but I think you get the point.
And then we talked
about poly which
gave us rules for how
electrons can be together
in one of these orbitals.
OK?
So you have wave
functions that wiggle.
We don't know how to
interpret what they mean,
but we know that their square
gives you the probability
distribution of that electron.
And we know that
these electrons also
have another important quantity
associated with them, a spin,
and the spin can only be one
of two values, up or down.
OK?
That is the information we
need to go to energy levels.
OK?
To this point, this is a
review, but it's about to be--
well, maybe
something some of you
know, but it's about to
be a little different.
OK?
So I want to make sure
we all understand this.
Once I know that you can
have two kinds of spin,
and once I know that you get
energies out of this equation,
then the answer to
the energy levels,
to what energy
levels are, is there
are these things that you fill.
There are these things that
you fill with electrons.
How do you fill them?
I keep blocking the screen,
but it's fun to go in there.
It makes me feel
important maybe.
I don't know.
Never mind.
How do you fill them?
I'll use this.
Oh, yeah.
What do you do here?
What's going on?
I want to fill these orbitals.
Do I fill this one
AUDIENCE: You start
at the lowest end
and work to the highest.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, and when do I stop?
AUDIENCE: When you
run out of electrons.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: When
you run out of electrons.
How many electrons did I have?
AUDIENCE: 29.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It depends
on the atom or molecule which
is where we are now or solid.
Now, that is really
in a way-- the reason
I'm focusing on it is this
is the key quantum mechanical
nature thingy,
property of materials,
I want you to come away with
being able to understand
and calculate in this class.
OK?
It's these energy levels.
This is the most important
thing I want you to come away
with from this class.
Why?
Well, we can calculate
other things,
and I've talked about that.
We can calculate energies.
We can calculate
binding energies.
all kinds of things,
but these energy levels are
purely quantum mechanical.
Right?
There where those electrons
want to be in energy,
and they matter so much to
the properties of materials.
So I want to focus on
these and connect them
to real exciting problems.
OK?
And make sure that
you understand
where they come from and
also how to calculate them
and what they can mean.
So that's where we are.
So that's why I keep
drawing things like this.
You see me just drawing this.
Right?
Now, what did I draw?
I don't know.
I drew a bunch of levels.
Right?
If I'm a little more
careful, and I do this,
now what am I drawing?
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Energy diagram.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Energy diagram.
OK, good.
What is it though?
Do we know?
AUDIENCE: Like there's
no electrons in there.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
OK, and it's
the solution to which problem?
Actually, this is
infinite square well.
So that's not the
hydrogen atom, but those
are the energy levels
you get for the solution
of the hydrogen atom.
OK?
Now, if I ask you what this
is though without putting
any electrons down, we don't
know, but what if I do this?
Now, what is it?
Hydrogen, what about now?
AUDIENCE: Lithium.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Lithium, what is this?
Oh, I love this one.
AUDIENCE: Carbon.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Carbon, carbon,
it's a beautiful material.
I love carbon.
OK?
I almost feel like you
need a little moment.
When you draw the
energy levels of carbon,
you need a little
moment of respect.
Now, but you see,
this is what we did.
We solved for these wiggles.
We got energies, and
we put them in order
from lowest to highest.
And then we said how many
electrons do we have?
Six, OK, fill them,
and then there
are rules that we talked
about about how you fill them.
Now, why am I
going through this?
Well, because that is only
good for what kind of material?
That is only a correct picture
for what kind of material?
Atoms, that's an atomic picture.
We solve for the atom, and
this is true-- and remember,
I said that we can solve
for the hydrogen atom
and see the whole
periodic table.
Right?
Powerful stuff, but
this is only an atom.
These are how you would fill
the energy levels of an atom,
and we've talked about this.
But see now, we're going
onto other things, where
you bring atoms together,
and you form molecules.
This is not a chemistry class.
So I'm not going to spend
a lot of time telling you
about sigma orbitals, pi
orbitals, bonding orbitals,
antibonding orbitals.
That's not what
we're about, but I
do need you to understand that,
when you bring atoms together,
the orbitals from those
atoms come together
and form new orbitals.
They form molecular orbitals.
OK?
Now, in this case, you're
seeing the H2 molecule,
and this is from this website.
There's lots of great
websites that talk
about molecular orbital theory.
OK?
And in this case, you
brought two s electrons
together, see, from a hydrogen
atom over here and a hydrogen
atom over there, and they
drew those energy levels.
And then they brought
them together,
and it turns out, when
you bring to 1s levels
together to form a molecule,
you get two new levels.
Right?
And the chemists love names, and
so they gave this one a sigma
1s, and that's a sigma star 1s.
Those are just two
new levels that
are formed, when you bring
these atomic levels together.
Now, all the same rules-- and
one of them, ah, two points--
one of them is a
bonding orbital.
See, this actually looks like
I brought two circles together,
and they overlapped.
That's a bonding orbital.
OK?
Another one of them, though,
is an antibonding orbital.
All right?
And an antibonding orbital
is higher in energy.
So it's going to come up higher.
Its energy is going to be
higher than the bonding orbital,
when you bring two
orbitals together.
And often, an
antibonding orbital
will actually have
a node, which means
there's zero chance
of any electron being
in between, exactly in between.
That doesn't sound
very binding-y.
Right?
Doesn't have a lot of
appeal for bonding,
if there's like a
plane of no existing.
Now, why would that be possible?
Doesn't it seem
from this picture--
I took to 1s orbitals, and
I brought them together.
Right?
How can I get a
node between them?
AUDIENCE: Is it [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Not quite.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Coulomb repulsion.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It is actually.
It does have to do
with Coulomb repulsion,
but there's something
more basic here at play.
How is it that I can
bring two spheres,
probability spheres
like this together
and have two orbitals
that form, one of which
has a node in between,
and one of which is
like really nicely happy bound.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Not quite, any other?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It looks like the
infinite square well there.
You've got the ground state
that doesn't have any nodes
and then the first excited
state does, the same deal.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
Well, so that's exactly right.
We're not bringing together
probability distributions.
OK?
That is not the right
way to think about it.
I won't stand in front anymore.
We're not bringing together
probability distributions.
We're bringing together
wave functions,
and then when those
come together,
they form a probability
distribution or two,
in the case I just showed you.
And we all know that,
when waves come together,
they can do what and what?
AUDIENCE: Construct
and deconstruct.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
They can construct, and they
can deconstruct one another.
Sounds like they're
going to have
like a philosophical discussion.
So that's what's happening.
We're bringing the
wave function together,
when we bring atoms together
and molecules together.
We're bringing
their size together.
Oh, size, you can't get away
from size being so important,
and we're solving for
the collective psi.
And when you bring waves
together, they have phase,
and they can form constructive
and destructive interference,
as we talked about in
lectures one and two,
and that's what's
happening here.
And then you square those,
and you get new orbitals
which have those properties.
OK?
So this is the simplest
example which is H2 molecule,
and then we fill those orbitals.
And when we fill these
orbitals, when we draw them
for a molecule, very often,
I'll lose this notation,
because there isn't--
and I'm not going to go
through this notation,
mostly because I can't
remember past sigma and pi.
But there's a whole
lot of notation
out there for
molecular orbitals,
and it depends on the
symmetry and the group
symmetry of the molecule
you're working with,
and there are rules
and all that stuff.
But all we're going
to need in this class
is to know that, when
you have a molecule,
and you calculate
this wave function
which gives you the wiggles.
And then you square it,
you get the distributions,
and that helps set
the energy levels.
It tells you where those
energy levels are going to be,
that will just draw
them like this.
Right?
Now, this is how
I'll draw molecules,
the energy levels of molecules,
and again this is it.
This is one of the most
important properties
I want to focus on,
because this is everything.
This is where those electrons
are in energy space,
and I can plot them.
I can look at their energy,
and there's all kinds
of important information here.
OK?
And so what this
means is usually I'll
leave a space here.
Does anybody know
what this is called?
AUDIENCE: Gap.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right.
This is the gap,
because that's how many
electrons I had in my molecule.
Not my atom, but in my molecule.
So I do the same thing.
I calculate energy levels,
I fill them up, and I stop.
I apply some rules,
like you wouldn't
have one level with two
electrons up, Pauli exclusion.
Right?
And then I stop,
and then there's
another level beyond that.
Oh, that's important.
So we're going to
talk about that today.
There's another level beyond
that that's not filled,
but the distance in
energy between these
is called the gap, and
it's really important.
And the energy gap is
what determines all kinds
of properties about a material.
It determines how
it absorbs light.
it conducts charge.
It can determine things about
its magnetic properties,
certainly transport properties.
And what's going to
happen, and that's
why I really want
to make sure we all
understand this for a molecule.
What's going to happen
is, when we go to solids--
on Thursday, we're
going to start talking
about moving to solids--
this is going to happen.
These are no longer
simple lines.
These go like this,
and that's really cool.
That happens because
you're putting them
in a periodic arrangement.
That's called a band structure.
It doesn't happen for molecules.
They're just little flat
lines, like they are in atoms.
OK?
So are we all good with this?
Are there questions?
Energy levels,
energy levels, need
to know about energy levels.
No questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when you
put up every central gas
and you calculated
all the total energy,
if you like have big molecules--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --you got huge gap and
it's harder to identify that.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Which one?
What's harder to identify?
AUDIENCE: Ammonia.
Because if you have one
more unit, for example--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: One more.
AUDIENCE: --some group.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
So you put an electron here?
Or what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So when you
calculated the wave function--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --how did you know
the electron wave function
for this type of ammonia?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Well, that's--
Yeah.
So that's where really
lecture three covers that.
Where basically, you need
to use an approximation
to the Schrodinger equation,
and that approximation
that we're using
in this class is
called density function theory.
But then you simply what
goes into that equation
is the approximations
you choose,
and the positions of the atoms
and the number of electrons.
And once you have
that, you basically
are solving for the psi.
You're solving for these.
Right?
And you get them and
their energies out,
and it's in the outputs
of the nanoHUB runs.
OK?
Now, one last thing before
we go back to solar fuels
that I want to make sure
we feel our oneness with
are these basis functions.
So this is a slide from another
lecture, an older lecture,
but I just want to
be sure we understand
what we're doing here.
OK?
So we said we needed to
make size for our materials.
We need the code to give us psi.
Now, for a hydrogen atom,
these are analytic functions.
Right?
They're like sines, cosines,
but for more complex material,
a complex atom, they
can look like this.
They can be really complicated.
OK?
So but a computer
can't just draw lines.
Right?
A computer can't do that.
It needs to have some
mathematical representation
for that function, and
that's what a basis set is.
But as I stressed
last week, this
is a new sort of not
a problem, but it's
a parameter that is not present
in classical simulations.
But it's one you have to
be very carefully aware of,
and you have to know
when you've converted it.
OK?
And the question
came up last week
of when is a basis
set converged?
OK?
And what do I mean?
Well, I can make a
basis out of anything--
Gaussians, exponents,
plane waves.
I can make a basis
out of wavelets
which are really interesting
hat-like functions.
But I can take any function,
and if I add enough of them
in the right places, and they
have the right width and size,
I can recreate a curve.
That's what we're
doing, but I want
to have as few as possible.
OK?
So this is a basis set
study that somebody did
and randomly put on the
web, which I randomly
found and didn't credit,
which I should have.
Anyway, this is the
number of basis functions
going this way, number
of basis functions,
and that's the energy.
And you can see that the
energy is going to change,
as you increase the
number of basis functions,
and there's this thing
called the basis set limit.
Sometimes it's called the
complete basis set limit,
and that complete basis set
limit is basically just saying,
hey, I've represented
my wave function
now numerically correctly.
So infinite number of basis
functions should give you that.
We don't have
enough computer time
to have that many basis
functions, because it
gets really long and slow.
So we don't do that.
Usually, we do calculations out
here, and maybe we extrapolate.
OK?
Or we just do a few
cases, and we say,
well, my results are converged.
But when is a basis
set converged?
It's a really important
point of quantum mechanical--
hey, that would be like
a good quiz question.
Right?
Like it's a really
important part of quantum
mechanical simulations are
always a quiz question.
It's not a bad one.
Is it converged here,
or is it converged here?
You know what answer
I'm looking for.
AUDIENCE: Depends
on the problem.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It depends.
I love that answer
for this class.
It depends, because
here, I'm plotting
the total energy of
the whole system,
but is that what I want?
Is that what I'm calculating?
I don't know, maybe, but what if
I'm actually calculating this?
What if I'm calculating the gap
between the highest occupied
and lowest occupied level?
Well then, I should plot
that versus the basis set,
and that, this line, the total
energy may converge like this.
Whereas, if I do the gap, it
kind of goes-- maybe it's here,
and then I get
another value here,
and then everything is fully
converged all the way in.
So the gap value
converged there.
You don't know.
Different properties will
converge differently,
and you start to
get a feel for it,
as you do more calculations.
I'm not expecting you to get
to that point in this class,
but I want you to
understand this.
It's really important.
OK?
So basis sets must be converged.
That's one point.
This can lead to big tables.
Chemists love big tables.
So it's actually a perfect fit.
So you see papers like this.
Oh, you can go to bse.pnl.gov,
and let's see, maybe I can just
go there really quickly.
And you can see,
oh, look at that.
There's the nanoHUB.
We're coming.
We're coming, and look at this.
Oh, this is beautiful.
See, many basis sets have
been made over the years.
Right?
And so here, they are.
Look at all these basis sets
for different-- and you see,
I can scroll down here.
Look at these basis sets.
You have a few of these to
choose from in the nanoHUB,
but look at how many there are.
These are all
published basis sets,
and you can go to
a place like this.
And you can click on one, like
3-21G*, and you can click on--
well, I don't think that--
and you can say what
code am I going to use?
Right?
And then, you can say get the
basis sets, and there they are.
And there are the papers,
where basically, they're
trying to say what is the
fewest number of Gaussians
that we can use to
represent these atoms?
So basis sets are fit to
atomic orbital wave functions.
OK?
And this is just a
certain form, where
you have the exponent
of the Gaussian
and a coefficient
of the Gaussian.
And I'm not going
to go into details,
because we don't need them.
OK?
There's a lot of
work on basis sets.
There's also a
lot of papers that
were published in the 1970s
and also '80s using basis sets,
like this, that show
really good answers using
like Hartree-Fock theory or
density functional theory
even but for the
completely wrong reason.
Because they used a level of
theory that wasn't accurate
and a basis set that
wasn't converged,
because the computers couldn't
go to larger basis sets,
and so the errors canceled.
So there are many papers
with really nice agreement
with experiment from theory
that are complete nonsense,
because they're using very
inaccurate theory and really
bad basis sets.
And so the errors cancel, and
you get beautiful results.
It's something that
we need to be aware of
and understand in this
class, but we're not
going to go into great detail in
all these different basis sets.
But you can go there,
and there's just a lot
of information there.
And you can play around, and you
can make big tables like this.
I don't recommend
that you do this.
But this was a study, this
is like the kind of thing--
I think that some people
really like big tables.
This one goes on and
on and on, by the way.
It never stops.
It almost never stops.
And you see, different
levels theory here.
These ones we
haven't talked about.
That's LDA, Hartree-Fock and
then different basis sets.
You see?
And some property,
the binding energy
and some other properties
that they care about.
OK?
Yeah.
Not expecting you
to do that, but I
want you to be aware
of how big of a concern
this is in quantum
mechanical calculations.
Any questions about basis sets?
Basis sets.
The last theory
point, last question
I want to ask, so we
asked, with basis sets,
how do we know when
we're converged?
Well, it depends.
When you add more basis
functions or do a larger basis
and things don't
change, your converged.
But there's another
bigger question,
which is how do we know when
the calculation is right,
that we talked about here.
Now, this is very
important, and it
goes to the point I just made.
Just because you
agree with experiment,
if you're not doing your
calculations carefully,
it can be still dangerous.
OK?
But let's suppose that you
have done your calculations
carefully, and you have
converged your basis set.
And you have checked everything
else about your code,
and you're asking
the question of which
of these structures of carbon--
remember, I really like carbon.
Which of these three
structures-- a ring,
a kind of bowl, or a cage--
gives you-- is most
stable for 20 atoms?
That's a pretty simple question.
Right?
This is the question I asked
as a second-year grad student,
a few years ago now.
Who laughed?
Sam?
And it was really
cool, because see,
you could try one
level of theory
and work really hard to
converge it completely.
And you'd get, for
example with LDA--
something you can
do on the nanoHUB--
you would get that the cage,
this guy, is the lowest energy.
This means the most stable.
And then you would do another
level of theory, Hartree-Fock
or this other thing
that you also have,
this is called the GGA.
It's another flavor of
density function theory,
and you would get
exactly the opposite.
You would get that the
ring is the most stable,
and the cage is
the least stable.
So what's going on?
What's going on?
Two different DFT
functionals gave me
completely different answers,
and I've converged everything.
AUDIENCE: Two more functionals.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Two more functionals.
Now, that's actually
a really good idea,
and it's actually
what people do.
OK?
In fact, you see, if you go to--
I think I left
this web page open.
Here's one of the
codes that does
density functional theory
and other quantum chemistry
calculations.
It's called Gaussian.
And if you look in
their 2009 version,
this is a code you
have to pay for.
There's lots of codes
that are free, by the way.
NWChem, if anybody wants to
play with a code, download it,
that does quantum
chemistry, that's
a pretty darn good one that's
free which you can download,
and there are others.
I'm happy to provide a list.
But look at the
number of functionals
you have to choose from.
OK?
Here's a little bit
about density functional
theory and the methods, and
then here are the functionals.
exchange functionals.
You see S, XA, B, PW, G96, PBE.
That's one of the
ones on the nanoHUB.
Right?
And correlation functionals,
VWN, LYP, B95, and so
what you wind up getting--
and then it goes on,
standalone functionals,
hybrid functionals.
OK?
Here's some more.
User defined functionals, you
can actually make up your own.
Right?
So here's a short list
of some of the keywords
you can enter and get
different functionals out.
So now, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: All of them.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
All of them.
Well, sadly, I think
some researchers do that.
So here's the broader point.
OK?
Density functional theory is
an approximation in the way
that we use it in our codes.
The actual theory
itself could be exact,
but the way that it
has to be implemented
requires this
approximate functional,
as you learned in lecture three.
OK?
What functional do I use?
Well, some of these
have been well tested
for broad classes
of materials and are
known to do well for certain
properties, certain materials,
and known to do not
as well for others,
but it's mostly empirical in
terms of our understanding.
It's because it's been
tried for many systems.
OK?
And so in a way,
we're a little bit
back to the classical world.
In the sense that
density functional theory
is a beautiful theory,
but to make it practical,
you have to make
approximations that make it
so that you have almost
an empirical nature to it,
or a semi-empirical
nature which is what you
have in classical force fields.
Right?
In classical force
fields, the potential
is as good as the
complexity of the potential
and what you fit it to.
Right?
Density function theory is,
I think, much more powerful,
in the sense that
you can really solve
for the electronic
structure, but we
have the same kind of problem
in density functional theory.
So the functionals that I've
given you on the nanoHUB
are some of the
most popular ones,
but you always
need to be aware--
[NON-ENGLISH]---- of the fact that
we're making an approximation.
And yes, one way to check
is to try two functionals,
and if they don't disagree
too much, you may be OK.
That's not the most
gratifying way to do it.
Another way would be to
compare with experiment,
and that's actually the
most gratifying way.
Once you converge
everything else,
if you're functional
agrees with experiment
for the kind of
problem you're trying
to solve, then that's a pretty
good indication that it's
an accurate solution to
the Schrodinger equation,
but you are making
a approximations.
OK?
And that is something
that we won't--
as you can see, I don't
give you much options
on the nanoHUB, because I
don't really want to go there,
but I do want you
to be aware of this.
We are not solving
quantum mechanics exactly.
We cannot, and with
density functional theory,
there are some systems.
So in my graduate days,
I worked on a method
that goes beyond density
functional theory inaccuracy.
So it's a very accurate method,
very slow but very accurate.
And so I was
purposefully looking
for systems where DFT fails, and
I was very happy with this one,
where you basically
don't know the answer.
You can try
functionals, and you'll
get all kinds of
different results.
So the only thing you
can do in that case
is go to a higher
accuracy method.
OK?
What I found out is
that this method here
is the most accurate one, that
actually none of the functions
were right, and the bowl
was the most stable.
So it's pretty cool.
It was exciting.
What can I say?
I was a physicist at
the time, so you know.
I won't say anything more.
OK.
Now, let's go back to our
first application example.
Does everybody remember
this from last week?
OK.
So let me make sure we know why.
I want to make
sure we understand
why this is such an important
problem for quantum mechanics.
OK?
So sun shines on a molecule,
the molecule changes shape,
and that changed shape
is a higher energy.
So if you draw the
reaction, if you
draw the reaction
coordinate for this system,
It looks like this.
OK?
So that would be the trans
state and the cis state,
and this is the higher
energy that that forms,
and it stores that much
energy in the molecule.
OK?
Now, what we found
is that there's
all these molecules
that do this,
but they're not very
good solar fuels.
OK?
So there's lots of
them that do this trans
to cis photoisomerization.
So the sun makes it go, or light
makes it go, from one state
to another.
None of them are good
solar fuels on their own,
but we found this way of making
them in general into good ones.
And this is a slide
I skipped last week,
so I want to just very
quickly explain this again.
Because it's really
important to understand why
we're so excited about this.
If you put these molecules
that switch back and forth
onto a template, and the
template can be anything,
but here it's a nanotube.
But if you put them onto it,
and you covalently bind them--
that means you attach
them really strongly,
so they're not
going to come off.
Then, what you've done is
you've packed them in a way
that they're not
able to get out of.
So you've packed them
together, and they're not
allowed to get out, because
they're covalently bound.
Some self-assembly
work is weakly bound.
Some is not.
Here, it's really
strongly bound.
So they're really forced
into this packing.
Now, what does that mean?
Well, look up here for a minute.
It's a little busy,
but look at that cyan
curve, the light blue.
This is the spacing that they're
packing on on this template.
This is it, 4.2 angstroms.
OK?
And that's also exactly the
minimum of that molecule,
when it's in the T state, here.
When it's in the T state,
it's happy at that spacing.
It's happiest.
Right?
But when it's in
the cis state, you
see the cis state has
a different spacing
that it wants to be at.
That's the red curve.
Right?
These are the
kinds of curves you
should be getting in your
homework for problem two.
That's the curve
for the cis state,
and you can see that it's a
happy place is much further
out, but it can't
be much further out.
It does not have that
flexibility anymore.
So you've constrained
it to always
be in the trans, happy place,
in terms of its spacing.
Now, what that means is that,
you can see right away, what
that means is that, when
it's in the cis state,
the energy of the cis state
is going to be higher.
So already, what you've done is
you've made this state go up,
because you've sterically
inhibited it just
by forcing it to be this
close and never further apart.
In the gas phase or in solution,
when it goes back and forth
between trans and cis.
It's always going to
find its happy place.
They're not going to worry
about this, but here they can't.
But as I mentioned last week,
much more importantly even,
when you're in this highly
confined geometry, this highly
constrained rigid packing,
what you can do now
is you can play
chemistry between them.
So I can actually
create functional groups
on these molecules that
bond them to each other
and to themselves
in different ways,
depending on whether they're
in the cis or the trans state.
OK?
And what that does
is that allows me
to lower this and lower this.
That's the key.
OK?
So now, because the
key is, remember,
goal is to increase
this and this barrier.
Going back, we want to be
able to tune it separately.
And you can see that, if you
just look at this reaction
coordinate, if I
increase delta H,
it looks like I'm going
to probably decrease
the activation barrier
which is not a good thing.
Because that's related to the
stability of the fuel, when
it's charged, the lifetime.
These molecules
on their own last
in the charged state
for a few minutes.
That's not very useful.
So what we'd like to do is
to be able to change both,
and this trick
allows us to do that.
We push this up from
steric inhibition,
but we pull it back
down from reactions.
We pull this, from interactions,
we pull this down even more,
because we can customize
the interactions that
happen between these molecules
and within the molecule.
So that's the key.
That's the magic sauce.
Right?
Now, all that is fine,
except that, as I--
OK.
So we have this new
class of materials
we're very excited about.
We're making them in the lab.
We're designing
them on a computer.
They're going to save the
world, or maybe they'll
just de-ice windows, but
anyway, that's very exciting.
Now, all of that can be done
using classical force fields.
You can calculate
delta H. You could
try to get a good model of
potentials for these molecules.
You could maybe try
different potentials
and see when it agrees with
experiment and all that
and try to explore this phase
space using classical force
fields.
That is accessible.
You may not-- gesundheit--
you may not be accurate.
You may have some
worries about validating
the potentials and
all that, but you
can do this with
classical force fields.
You can get energies as a
function of these twists
in the bonds and try to
engineer it this way,
but you cannot talk about
the optical properties.
You cannot do that using
classical potentials.
You need the electrons, and this
goes back to our energy levels.
OK?
So now, it will come
in to play here.
We're going to go
back to energy levels.
You see, I can make
a really dense energy
fuel, a really highly
energy dense fuel,
but if it doesn't absorb
the sunlight efficiently,
then I can never charge it.
Right?
So that's a critical
part of this.
If it doesn't absorb sunlight
well, it's useless to me.
OK?
Now, so this is the thing
that we've been talking about,
but that part can be looked at
with potentials, if you wanted.
This part here, where you
absorb the light, cannot.
So here's the light that
comes down to Earth.
Right?
We talked about this.
That's the solar flux.
And the key point here is that--
I keep that?
We don't need that anymore.
The key point here is that those
molecules have energy levels,
like this and like this,
and they have a gap.
Right?
These are what we call occupied,
and these are unoccupied.
Unoccupied levels,
occupied levels,
I just don't want
to draw the arrows,
and that's the energy gap.
Now, why does the energy
gap matter with respect
to this picture?
Yeah?
At the same time--
one, two, no.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Because
all the absorption
are at certain frequencies--
or certain light
coming in at frequencies
with great enough energy that
surpass the energy gap.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why?
That's really good.
That's exactly right.
AUDIENCE: So it's too low.
It's not enough
energy to shut it off
from occupied to unoccupied.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
too low of energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Too
low of an energy, right?
So this is energy going--
this is wavelength
going that way.
So energy goes this way.
OK?
Right?
So there is going to be some
minimum energy below which
you can no longer absorb light.
The molecule is transparent.
That is the energy gap.
That's this energy gap here.
Any energy that that
molecule receives
that's from those photons--
and this is the energy.
Wavelength, as we know
same, as the energy.
Any photons it receives
from the sun that's less
than this just go right past.
They cannot get absorbed.
If I don't absorb a
photon, I don't do this.
I don't switch.
OK?
So this is important.
Now, the question
is what do I want?
Well, do I want the material to
have a very high gap or a very
low gap?
Out here would be a
very low energy gap,
and over here, it would
be a very high energy gap.
What do you guys
think I want here?
How would I get-- and I'm
going to collect energy only
above the gap.
So if my energy
gap is here, it's
only going to be this part
of the sun I can collect.
So where do you think
I want my gap to be?
Over here?
That's definitely
what you would think.
Why not just make this
material have almost no gap?
Right?
If it had almost no gap, then
if this were the gap, then
any little bit of sunlight
would excite electrons up,
and you'd absorbed the photon.
Why is that not a
good solar fuel?
AUDIENCE: They fall easily.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: They fall
back down easily.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well, they
certainly could fall back down,
and actually usually, they'd
be absorbed say up here,
and they'd usually trickle
down to here anyway
to the LUMO state.
That's called thermalization.
They could also fall back
down to the homo state
and re-emit a photon.
That's absolutely right,
but there's another reason.
AUDIENCE: Lower energy density.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Why?
AUDIENCE: There's a band
gap in the partial delta H.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
That's it.
So what are we doing
in storage materials?
What are we doing with
electrons in batteries,
in solar thermal fuels?
What are we doing
with those electrons?
AUDIENCE: Storing them.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
We are storing them.
Yes, but what are we
doing to make them--
what are we doing
when we convert them?
Maybe I should say it that way.
Same thing happens
in a solar cell.
I'm doing something
to these electrons.
AUDIENCE: Putting
them on a shelf.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
You know I love that analogy.
Yeah?
It's like pumping hydro.
Hydro pumping is one of
the best technologies
we know of to store energy.
It's even creating a little
stir here in the third row,
because he has read
the reports, and he
knows that there are
certain areas where
that's the only
game in town, pumped
hydro, a beautiful technology.
It works.
You pump water up a hill.
When you got too much
energy, and you let
it roll back down
when you need it.
Right?
Now, that's all we're
doing with electrons.
That's it.
It's the same exact thing.
We're pumping
electrons up a hill.
We're using light to do it here.
For a battery, when you
plug your electric car
in, you're using current
and electrons, potential,
voltage to do it, but you're
driving electrons up the hill.
And then you're trying
to keep them up there,
and then let them come
back when you need them,
when you need them
to release energy.
OK?
Now, if my gap is
really low, you
see, the hill, it's never
going to get to the top.
Here's my hill.
OK?
If my gap is only
this much in energy,
then I'm just going
to roll around here,
and I'm never going to
get any amount of storage.
Right?
So you want this to be
as large as possible,
because that's how
much energy you store.
But the gap can't be
any smaller than this,
or you're not going to give
those electrons enough energy
to get up the hill to go there,
so the material can go there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So let's see
you have some material
with some small
gap, and you just
have it exposed to sunlight
and then compare it
with some material
with a large gap.
Wouldn't they both on average
collect the same number
of high-energy photons anyway?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So with
the low-gap material,
you'd get some with height
that collect higher--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Great question.
AUDIENCE: High energy
photons, and then they
have some excited state.
And then the ones
with the high gap
will also have
that excited state,
but the ones with
the low gap will also
have these lower,
excited states.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On top of that?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
It's a great question,
and what you're talking
about is such a cool idea
in solar PV called hot carrier.
What you'd like to do is get
those excited, really high
energy electrons
out in solar cells,
before they come back down.
In this case, they
come back down.
See in this case,
they thermalize,
and the reaction happens in
the lowest excited state.
But it also happens
in solar cells,
because there are no hot
carrier solar cells today.
It's a great theory.
It's a great idea.
So this is the idea, and
there's a lot of active research
in this area.
And it's basically the
idea of multijunction cells
which are cells that work, and
in fact, the highest efficiency
solar cells to date
are multijunction,
triple-junction solar cells.
Where basically, you have
different band gaps together,
and those different band
gaps do exactly what you say.
OK?
They let you take some
electrons out here,
and then you have another
material with a higher gap,
and you can take them out here.
And then you have
another material
with an even higher gap, and
you can take those electrons out
there.
OK?
And see because
otherwise, what happens?
Otherwise, all the electrons
will-- in each case--
all the electrons
cascade down to here.
They all wind up in that
conduction band or that LUMO
state, if it's a molecule.
No matter what, that's just
the dramatic and traumatic loss
of solar materials.
Right?
Solar conversion, solar capture,
those electrons thermalize,
because that process
of thermalization
is so fast, that it's
very hard to beat.
The way you beat it in
multijunction solar cells--
42% maybe is the record,
something like that.
The way you beat it
is you literally just
stick a level in there.
So it's sort of a
cheat, but that's
the only way to do it that we
know technologically today.
If there were other ways
of extracting electrons out
at their higher energies,
you could do wonders
in solar capture and storage.
In the molecule, the
electron thermalizes down,
and the reaction goes in
that lowest excited state.
So that gap has to be
bigger than delta H. OK?
Does everybody see that?
It's a very good question.
So it's this
beautiful, constrained
optimization problem.
I love those, because
constrained optimization
problems, I want this
to be really big,
but I want this to stay not
less than an electron volt.
But then if this
is really big, I
can't absorb any of the light.
Right?
If I made delta H
huge, then I'd have
to have a gap that
was like here,
and I'd get almost
no solar efficiency.
These are beautiful problems
for materials design
and for computation,
because they're constrained,
but they're not
that constrained.
And using computers,
you can get your way out
of that, those
constraints, sometimes.
OK?
And that's what's, I
think, really exciting.
That's what your homework
is going to be about, and so
let's calculate one of these.
OK?
Because that is the key
to the optical efficiency.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is the gas thinner
than the just delta H or delta
H plus the base?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That's
a very good question, and--
AUDIENCE: He told me to ask.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's a very good question.
So in general,
most of these kinds
of photoactive molecules--
I've already talked to a
chemist, so I'm well armed.
Most of these
photoactive molecules
need the gap plus the
activation barrier,
because in the excited state,
you'll get a similar barrier.
It's not clear that's
always true though,
and so that puts more
constraints on this.
So it's even less of the
spectrum you can absorb,
basically.
Right?
If you want to store
1 1/2 electron volts,
and you need an electron volt
of an activation barrier,
that's a 2 1/2 v-gap minimum.
Which means you're closing
in on the UV, which
means your optical efficiency
is probably at most 5%, 8%, 10%,
at most.
Right?
That doesn't mean it's
a deal breaker at all.
But there are also
cases where you
do change the barrier
in the exciting state,
and so we're looking into that.
Now, I want another concept
here to come across which
is really important.
OK?
And that is nothing more than
these levels smoothed out,
and it's called the
density of states.
OK?
So if you do a calculation
of one of these molecules--
let me go back to here.
Oh, yeah.
You know we love this.
Have you all rated this
say a 10 out of 10?
Come on.
You know it's a 10 experience.
AUDIENCE: Someone gave it a 9.5?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: No.
That's an average.
OK.
I want to start using--
we're going to use a different
tool for our next homework.
We're going to use DFT
for solids, surfaces,
and molecules.
It's called SIESTA.
It's another free software
that you can download.
And it's solving
the same equations,
but it uses different
approximations, different basis
sets, and so forth.
OK?
But here, and you
see that basis sets
are called different
things, but I've still
tried to help by saying really
bad, mediocre, and OK, in terms
of the quality.
OK?
Again, that's not the
focus in this class.
Let's look at it, and we're
going to do a molecule here--
Uh-oh, there we go--
a molecule.
And I'm going to upload one,
and you're going to get these.
We'll give these
with the homeworks.
We'll put them on Steller.
So here's a trans state.
Let's do the phenyl.
Here's a trans state.
We're going to upload
it and simulate.
OK?
And this is doing just
what the other code does.
It's doing this self-consistent
cycle, where it's
solving for the wave function.
OK?
And it's getting
the wave functions
of all these levels for the
molecule I just entered.
So it's going to give
me all these levels.
That's what I want.
Now, the way this plots
it though is in something
called the density
of states, and all
that is, as we'll see in a
minute, is you take these,
and you turn it on the side.
OK?
So let's take a look.
Is it done?
Yes.
There it is.
Oh, this is a
beautiful solar fuel.
It's actually got two
photo-switchable molecules
hanging off the same
azobenzene ring.
But anyway, and this--
where is the-- there we go.
OK.
So the key outputs, so
it tells you some things,
and then you can go
to Density of States,
and this is a very
important property.
OK?
This is the way that we like
to look at energy levels,
especially in solids.
So we're going to be
looking at DOS plots
when we get to solids.
OK?
But in molecules, you
can look at the DOS plot
as well, and
basically, what it is
it's just these levels
turned on their side.
So if there's a bunch of
levels near each other,
you'll get a higher
peak in the DOS.
You want to think about
it as averaging over
the likelihood of finding
states at these energies.
Has anybody seen a DOS plot?
How many of you have seen a
DOS plot, a density of states?
One or two?
That's OK.
They're energy levels
turned on their side.
Right?
Now, when we do solids,
it gets really fun.
It gets really fun
when we do solids,
because when we do
solids, like I said,
these things go like this in
a space yet to be determined.
And then you turn
those on their sides,
and you still get the
same kind of DOS plot.
But for molecules, this is
what it would look like.
So there's a little
smoothing going on,
but you're also
representing how many states
you have near these energies.
So that's why it's called
the density of states.
Right?
Gesundheit.
Does everybody see that
this is that energy gap?
This is it.
That's the energy
gap, but there's
more in the density of states.
OK?
So the energy gap, now I can--
watch this-- I can go
back, and I can magically
put on some functional groups
and go to the amino benzene
case, and I can do
that simulation.
How many people really want
to hear about hydrogen storage
or don't care?
Be honest.
Really want to hear
about hydrogen storage?
In the back.
Because I really want to make
this point, because also,
this will be the basis
of your homework.
But I can also take the
first 10 minutes of Thursday
and talk about hydrogen storage.
Hydrogen storage, nobody cares
about hydrogen storage anymore,
do they?
In the back, we have
one hydrogen storage.
The hydrogen economy,
it was a big myth.
Well, it's not a myth,
but it's a long way off.
That we'd all be--
I'm not sure I would
use that-- that we'd all
be driving hydrogen-powered
cars in this decade
was a little bit of an
exaggeration, to say the least.
So here's this guy.
Now, what I did
is I decorated it.
I did some, like I
thought-- oh, by the way,
your computation is only
as good as what's up here.
Right?
So you need to think about
what you want to simulate,
and here, we thought,
well, we had this one.
OK?
We had this one, and it's
not quite the same angle,
but it's close.
OK?
So these guys are
going to switch,
when the sun shines on
them, and store some energy
and switch back.
But I decided that I wanted
to try to do something
about the strain in this state.
Again, you're trying
to lower, remember--
you're trying to
lower these states,
or change them, figure
out how to tune them.
Right?
So what I did is we
put a group in there.
You can see, you put
a group in here which
is going to cause some bonding,
when it's in the trans state.
And you put another
group here which
causes some bonding
between those OH
groups and the nitrogen,
and that adds to the energy.
It lowers the energy.
Right?
Now, as I said, we do that
with quantum mechanics,
because it's actually not
that big of a problem,
but that doesn't
tell me whether--
I may have made this a great
solar thermal fuel that
can never absorb light.
And so you got to go, and you've
got to look at these things,
like the density of states.
OK?
And so here they are together,
and you can see that in--
so that's one.
OK.
So one is now bold, and you can
see that my modifications have
done some interesting things.
My chemical
modifications have really
changed where those
energy levels are.
Now, remember, they're
getting filled from here.
Remember the filling.
Right?
You draw from the bottom, the
most energy favorable ones,
all the way up, and
then you fill them up,
and you stop filling here.
Right?
You stop filling here,
and that's your gap,
and you can see that the gap
has changed considerably.
So the gap has
changed considerably,
and that changes
what kind of sunlight
that molecule can absorb.
Now, what's nice about
having the density of states
is that, you see,
I'm getting-- in all
of the energy levels-- is I'm
getting more than just the gap.
Right?
I'm getting other things.
I'm getting shapes and peaks,
and here's a double peak.
There's a single peak.
Here's a little narrow peak,
but there's a really broad thing
with like three
peaks and a shoulder.
Right?
That matters too.
That matters a whole lot.
OK?
And the reason is that to a
very, very crude approximation,
you can consider these peaks in
where the states are in energy
as the places where
this molecule will
be able to absorb light.
OK?
And so you can match this
up with the solar spectrum.
Right?
Because what you want
is for the molecules
to be able to absorb light,
where there's a lot of light.
And you don't really care
about them absorbing light.
You don't necessarily need
them to have huge peaks,
where there's no sunlight.
Right?
So now, you have an
interesting comparison
of where these molecules
tend to absorb light
and where the light is.
OK?
So let's go back
to this and make
sure we know where I'm going.
OK?
So see, we talked about--
just another five
minutes or so I think
to finish this discussion.
We talked about how,
well, you don't want--
there are constraints on just
thinking about how big of a gap
you want.
Because it's a
constrained optimization
problem with this thing and
this thing and this stuff.
Right?
We just talked about that.
Now, I'm going to tell you
there's another problem,
and that is that this
state is also photoactive.
So this state can absorb
light which makes it go back.
Well, that's a bummer.
Right?
That is a bummer.
Now, what that
means is that, when
I shine light on
this material, I
will never get it
all to convert.
I will never charge
all of the material
and make it all go
from here to here,
because there's constantly
a competition at play.
Some of it will be going
this way, and some of it
will be going that way.
And what holds the key to
determining how much of which
one is made?
What holds the key?
AUDIENCE: The ratio
of delta H plus EA.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
actually, but the delta H
and EA are out of
the picture for now,
because I'm only talking about
the absorption efficiency.
What type of photons it
could absorb and what else?
What type of photons
it can absorb and?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How many of
those types of photons--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Your solar cell.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Exactly, and this.
Right?
So you're given this much
photons on planet Earth.
You're give given the yellow,
if you go up a little bit.
Right?
We're not going to charge
our fuels in space.
So this is what you
got, the red, and that's
where the photons are in
energy, in wavelength energy,
same thing.
Now, I'm giving you the
fact that some molecules--
let's go back here.
I can't just delete one, can I?
I'm going to do one more
simulation while I talk.
I wish it wouldn't show
my picture everywhere.
I'm going to do the cis state.
OK?
You see, some molecules
in their cis state,
they're still photoactive,
which means they go back here,
when you shine light on them.
What that means is that there's
going to be a stationary state.
When I hold the
fuel out in the sun,
the light is converting this
into this, as well as this
into this with some
efficiency in both directions.
And there will be
a stationary state
that gives me a
percentage, or a yield,
or as it's called
in the literature
a quantum yield, of
charged material.
How much is it?
Well, in isolated azobenzene,
when you don't do anything
to it, it's 25%.
I can only charge
25% of this stuff
in the photo-stationary state,
when I hold it out in the sun.
And you can see why this
is such an important part
of the problem, I
will remind you,
a purely quantum mechanical
part of the problem.
Because if I increase this, I
work so hard to increase this
by a factor of three
or four, and then I
can only charge a
fourth of it, that's
a whole factor of four hit.
If you can only charge a
fourth of it at a time,
it's four times less useful.
So it's effectively changing
this by four times back.
Right?
So this is critical.
How much of this can you charge?
Right?
And that comes from
the quantum mechanics.
Now, the way that you
get it is by looking at--
and I'll go through
the equations
on the next line a minute.
So here it is now in
the charged state.
OK?
So it's flipped.
It's done its flip.
You can see, it's rotated
those nitrogen bonds.
It's a beautiful thing, kind of
an emotional moment in a way.
And you go back to here,
and you look at your DOS,
and now this is
kind of hard to see.
Isn't it?
One of these is the cis
state that I just mentioned,
and it's different.
I can't see, because
there's two trans
states here and one cis state.
I don't think there's any
way to just do simulations
two and three, but I think you
know what I'm talking about.
There's a density of
states for the trans.
These levels here
turn on their side,
and there's a density of
states for the cis state.
And matching that
with the solar flux
is what will give you the
photo-stationary state.
It will give you the quantum
yield of the material.
OK?
That will be your
second homework.
So this, let's see, this is
two ways that you could do it.
OK?
One way is you could just assume
that all of the photons higher
in energy than the gap are
absorbed and lead to a switch.
And if you do that, then the
fraction of the molecules
in the cis state, if
you let them be x,
you can show that
it's just going
to be a simple integral
over the solar spectrum,
that this I function,
up to the gap times x.
That's how many are
in the cis state.
Gesundheit.
[NON-ENGLISH] Equals the number
that are in the trans state,
1 minus x, times the integral
over the number of photons that
convert the trans.
OK?
That's just
stationary-- that's just
telling you that the change
in the concentration of cis
is the same.
It's like a reaction
kinetics equation,
the rate of going from
one state to another times
the number in that state equals
the same as the other way.
That's all we've done here.
But it gets more interesting if
you use the density of states,
because now, you
have the absorption--
what I'm calling the absorption.
Again, it's a
crude approximation
for the absorption, but
let's just call it that--
of the cis state as a
function of the wavelength,
convoluted with, or
times, the solar spectrum.
Where you have states in
both is where it matters.
Right?
Where you have states in both
is where you hit the integral,
and it's when those
are taken together
that you can calculate
more accurately than just
using the gap.
You can calculate the
photo-stationary yield,
and you get this all
from those energy levels,
those beautiful energy
levels that we started
this lecture talking about.
OK?
That yield is so important,
because it can kill your--
great idea for improving
delta H can get
killed if the yield isn't good.
OK?
Maybe I'll spend 10 minutes
on hydrogen storage.
Nobody raised their hands,
but we'll do another poll.
And we're going to start
moving now-- you'll
have a homework on this.
It'll be lots of fun, and
then on Thursday, we're
going to move into solids.